F COURSE, WILLAY OUT OVENEXT FE
MUCH.ANK YOU SO
SECURITY MEASURES BEG TRUMP'S C
APIN
HOTEL.HEY'RE WORKING
ENFORCEMENT.
YS ARE
ED TO BEHERE.
ARPO TO HANDLE
ANOLCEr: WELL, IU THAT QUESTION
ULD TELL YES.ING TO THE CF PO
OUT HERE, HEAYS TH
ESOURCES AND
COURTHOUSE AT MIGHT SHOW UP
OW.
NOW, WHEN PRESSED FOSPECIFICS,
POLICE SAID TT IS
SOMETHING THAT HIS POLICE
DEPARTMENT IS NOT GOINTHER CONC
ENFORCEMENT ACROSS
IS READY TO DEAL WITH THE
POSSIBLEWDPOR
SUPPORTERS OF THE FORMER
PRESIDENT AS WELL AS PROTESTERS
WHO MIGHT SHOW UE THE
FEDERAL COURTHOUSE IN DOWNTOWN
MIAMI.HIS HOUR THERE ARE FEW
RR OUTSIDE OF THIS
SE, AND IT IS STILL
UNCLEAR R MIAMPO
OF THEME THEFOLKS THAT ARE GOIN
PRESIDENT.
HERE NOW IE  POLICE
TH AFTERNOON.RLIER
BRIING ENOUGH
RESOURCEE A CRD
ANYWHERE FROM 5,0 TO
WE DON'TXPSU.
RECIATE THE PU HELP,YBODY GOING
EXPRESSING TVES  A
SOUE ABOUTTLY JUST WHE ALLOFPUS
RESOURCES AR THIS HOUR, WHEN
OU MIGHT
D UP SAYING,T  TE'REWILL DON
EXACTLY HOW MANY PEOPLE TURN OUT
TOMORROW.S OWD OF ABOUTP SUPPOR
EARLIER THIS AFTERNOON.
AT ONE PTE
SOME OF THT OU
THE .
HOWEVER, POLICE HERE WERE ABLE O
EXTREMT GROUPS ONLIN LE THREA R
UNDERSTANDING ACCORDING TO
ENFORCT S THAT GROUP
OF F ACTS HAVE BEEN TASKED
WITHHROUGH SOCIAL MEDIA
POSTS FOR ANY POSSIBLEHRTO FEDE
DOWNTOWN MIAMI.'RE TOLD AOKT WE
BECAUSE TALKINT
TROUTH FLORIDA AHEAD
OF TOMORROW.
VEABOUT ERRCEMENT OFFICIALT WE'
CREDIBLE THREATS TMIAMI.EF FOR ,
FLORIDA, THAOU. US
CE
OVER TRUMP'S ARRAIGNNTY HNSON, E
ADNI
PREPAREDOMSOE ERLS US.SAY THEY'
WATCHIHA IN
MIAMI SEEMEDLAED
THELN SOMEAREAS, A FEW PLASTIC W
NENED AT THE U. , GIVEN
AT WE'VE
HEARD AND THOSE GE
ORRRICADINEPARING E WORST?  TSU
WHOLE LOE  FOR
T CAMETE IN N LIKE
EMA TO ADEAT
.
MAL, PE, CAL LAW ENFORCEMEN DE '
THTILY MONITORING
ALTICR,
PARTICULARLY GIVEN SOMOF
>> SOME OF THELOOFOUEEN DOWNAMDI
HEARD FROM MEMBERS OF CONGRESS
NOW, OBVIOUSLY PEOPLE HAVE ATO .
THE , ARMPOFPLTHSPEECH.
WAY THINK, TO
GETTING OF
L?AKISY MY
PRCIT
IRRESPONSIBLE.VE HEARD THE LCOTY
METREMISTSPUBLIC LIFE SEEKOTHE
UNACCEPTABLE BEHAVIOR ACCEAB
AND, FRANKLY, VIOL I CAN RS
SO OR  SOME OF OUR LEAENGAGING
KIND OF K THERSIBILITY, ANKLY, T
RAND CALL IT OUT Y TO THOSEO AO
ITA FERA
THREATEN A OFFICCOUC
THD BOYS AND THOSE WHOUS
MIGHT BE ON THE GROUND IN
D OFOS
E CHARGES  TRUMP IN TH,  S
THE SAFETPLE BOTH AT THE RT SE,
RUDY GIULIANI I AGO AUTORIRY NE
TO
EV CLASSIFIED,MPARTMENTALIZED DT
LOUNGINGUNBOXES,
PRESIDF TOS PEOPLEDLE CLASSIFIEN
N
FASHIOKIFS.WE DON'T TALABOF SS.
FOR DONALD TRUMP TE
DO THI ALARMING.
I'ERE FALLOU
AND I'M CERTAIL,L BEHO YOUREHII
E FOR DOE THE GRAVITDONE